a few years ago the iPhone 3G was just
being released and Indiana Jones was all
of a sudden chasing aliens we also did
something quite crazy we developed a
classic point-and-click adventure game
we love fantasy and many of us had
serious World of Warcraft addiction
issues so we put Oryx dragons the undead
and all kinds of other creatures into
our game that you would normally expect
to find in a role-playing game reactions
were fantastic and the book of unwritten
tales became one of the best rated and
most successful adventure games in the
last decade after making the critter
Chronicles
a standalone add-on two years later we
finally wanted to develop a proper and
bigger second part and that's exactly
what we did welcome to the world of the
book of unwritten tales to
[Music]
all right me first okay now give me my
notebook please hey I thought we had a
deal maybe you weren't quite clear in
the conditions with the book of
unwritten tales - we want to stay true
to the genres roots it's an old-school
point-and-click adventure in the
tradition of Monkey Island Discworld and
Simon the sorcerer this means there are
tons of puzzles to solve items to use
and things to discover so what was that
number again six four seven three one
[Music]
number and with 20 to 25 hours of
playing time the book of unwritten tales
- is one of the biggest adventure games
of the last 15 years
an old sword in a rock that poses
several questions what did the poor rock
do wrong to make someone want to stab
him who had enough strength to drive a
sword into the rock and above all who
profits from murder god I'd make a
fantastic detective story takes place
one year after the first chapter in C
stone the capital humans some kind of
plague is spreading it is transforming
dirty and dangerous fantasy creatures
for example a Hippogriff into oil the
plague must be stopped in Archmage
Alastair the leader of the alliance
would be the right man for the job
but there is a small problem the
Archmage murdered by Wilbur whether Fame
there's something stranger foot cheap
mark my words I don't believe a word of
it someone's responsible for this
epidemic and someone wants to hurt our
friends a way to see stone
someone tries to pin the murder on
Wilbur who has just been appointed the
first professor for magic and the
reopened school for wizardry and
witchcraft how along but who white and
Nate and the critter get caught in the
clutches of Nate's archenemy the red
pirate I ruin the Archmage have hidden
the artifact I don't know where it is
yeah yeah yeah you know cause if you
don't I can have you thrown off the
island
straight away all right then I know I'll
tell you if you let me go with three nah
four chests of gold I'm shut up idea
I'll let you live oh I want say I can't
your quick death if it's only where it
is
if that's your bestest offer it's time
for a quick getaway
[Music]
I also hit little people with glasses on
with pleasure
take that and then tap and how can I
hope Ravenna arranged marriage to an
elven Prince I don't have any intentions
of marrying anytime soon
oh darling we've been through that
already Prince Lally loss is going to be
arriving next week you will like him
he's charming and look he sent us a
picture of himself and his sister um
which of the two is the sister these are
just a few questions that are answered
in five large chapters the book of
unwritten tales 2 is an homage to
fantasy and role-playing games this
means our world is inhabited by the
typical fantasy characters that are
often provided hello ah why have you
always got to be in my face
you've been a caretaker for long what
exactly your duties I run the place
oh not in here woods without me just not
one no pcs that's a walk I see but don't
the teachers and the school
administration etc have a small share in
the success of the school right what
suit says you've had a little relish
dump disgusting will do do you run down
we always try to give our fantasy
creatures a little twist take our Bertha
Gardner for example he's an INT and if
answer actually trees shouldn't there be
bonsai Institute a fairly small
unattractive tree huh oh don't you see
how attractive you look if someone
disturbed you on the pot in the morning
you mean anyway what could I do free
might it'll be eaten Arbor has a problem
with the plants it's only one of several
tasks that Ivo can deal with at the
moment because in the game there are
usually several puzzles that you can
work on in parallel if you get stuck
anywhere you can always continue in
another place in the good old tradition
of the book of unwritten tales we are
trying to hide a whole lot of Easter
eggs and references in the game a few
years ago this dragon was causing a
whole lot of grief a bounty was put on
its head and all heroes of the land were
encouraged to hunt it down 40 brave
warriors penetrated its lair and slew it
they brought the head to the palace
where it was displayed in triumph the
strange thing was that a bit later more
adventurous came carrying an identical
head then more and more heroes arrived
some of the Easter eggs aren't even
commented on there in the game to give
you the players a lot of opportunities
to explore locations and discover new
details
[Music]
good good this is good
although the ground is still getting
closer for the puzzles in humor we once
again try to bring in what people liked
from the first game but regarding
technology and scope were able to do
much more this time for the first game
less than a hundred thousand spoken
words were reported while the second
part has more than 150 thousand part of
the jetty at least some of it survived
the explosion also the first game was
primarily animated by one animator and
now there are six animators working on
the second one if I'm lucky this will go
all the way up to the island but somehow
I really doubt it will it's a huge
effort that we can partly make thanks to
our Kickstarter backers in early 2014 we
asked our fans that they would be
interested in some optional features and
extra content for the game and oh yes
they were thank you for that
[Music]
oh hi Nate how's it going good for now
thanks to our backers we will implement
every location in the book of unwritten
tales with a technique called projection
mapping that allows for scenes to have
more spatial depth and a more natural
look without weakening the game's
performance we are also able to record
most of the soundtrack with the real
live Orchestra
[Music]
and we will have optional puzzles that
you can solve to unlock outfits for the
four main characters how's my favorite
daughter I'm your only daughter oh that
I had a hundred you are a would remain
something very special the other 99
would be as well though haha you're not
with the book of unwritten tales - we
hope to be able to give all fans of
classic and humorous point-and-click
adventure the experience they've long
been waiting for we're very proud of the
game and believe that all you Adventure
an RPG fans out there will really like
it the game will be released in early
2015 for PC Mac and Linux before that
you can also play it chapter by chapter
via Steam early access hello
whoa cheesy what does it want here my
name is Wilbur weathervane who is
speaking
it's scary to be here we're looking
forward to your feedback because with
your help we can improve the game even
more thanks so much for your loyalty and
support we wish you lots of fun with the
book of unwritten tales too
[Music]
you